shingles is a painful skin condition in
adults caused by the chickenpox virus
also known as the varicella-zoster virus
if you had chickenpox as a child
you still have the varicella-zoster
virus inside some of your nerves but not
in active form for unknown reasons the
varicella-zoster virus may become active
again in older people or those with
weakened immune systems
the reactivated virus travels along your
nerves to your skin causing symptoms
such as numbness
tingling
and pain
a red blistery rash quickly follows
these symptoms
shingles normally happens in a single
patch on one side of your body it may
also happen on one of your shoulders on
the side of your neck or head
within three to five days bumps in the
rash fill with fluid and become blisters
that look like chickenpox
next the blisters fill with pus which
forces them to break open and begin to
scab over
when the scabs fall off and the blisters
heal the pain usually goes away
these symptoms usually last one to two
months
you may experience a complication of
shingles called postherpetic neuralgia
or PHN which is pain even after your
rash has cleared up
other complications of shingles include
vision loss
if shingles occurs around your eye
pneumonia hearing problems brain
inflammation neurologic problems and
skin infections
both the chickenpox vaccine and the
shingles vaccine can dramatically reduce
your risk for getting shingles and post
herpetic neuralgia
there is no cure for shingles antiviral
drugs such as acyclovir can speed
healing and reduce the severity of the
rash when taken within three days after
the rash appears to reduce pain your
doctor may recommend over-the-counter
pain medication
calamine lotion cool compresses and an
oatmeal bath for severe post herpetic
neuralgia your doctor may prescribe
medications such as gabapentin